the batman is barely out in theaters
worldwide and people are already fan
casting their dream follow-up a sequel
to the batman hasn't officially been
announced as of the making of this video
that said the film teases more
adventures from the dark knight and as
rogue's gallery of foes moving forward
furthermore producer dylan clark has a
time frame in mind for the seemingly
inevitable follow-up to matt reeves
gritty blockbuster and warner brothers
intends to give one of the movie's
villains his very own spin-off series
all in all it seems that the studio
heads and filmmakers have high hopes for
this iteration of the batman franchise
of course even the slightest possibility
of a sequel to the batman is enough of a
reason to get fans talking about the
characters they'd like to see make an
appearance down the line penguin the
riddler and the joker have all had time
in the spotlight in recent years but the
batman vault boasts a wide array of
memorable baddies many of whom who have
arguably been overlooked undeserved or
flat out ignored in the live-action
movies gotham's caped crusader has a
long history with mr freeze that's
barely been explored in the films and
many fans would no doubt love to see a
serious exploration of that conflict now
that they've had time to recover from
arnold schwarzenegger's ill-fated turn
as a character in 1997's batman and
robin what killed the dinosaurs
it remains to be seen if the batman
filmmakers include mr freeze in a future
project numerous batman fans on social
media have been calling for mr freeze to
appear in the sequel to matt reeves film
causing the character to trend online in
the process meanwhile over on instagram
artist missouri has shown how the iconic
villain could look if he were to be
portrayed by english actor mark strong
the chilling illustration depicts strong
with icy white skin sporting a pair of
glasses that accentuate frieza's red
eyes the character's trademark black
suit is also on display giving him an
imposing and muscular appearance the
image is capped off with blue hues which
really enhance the freezing factor that
fans expect to be associated with this
particular villain the picture is much
scarier than arnold schwarzenegger's
version of the character from batman and
robin and some of missouri's followers
support the idea of seeing strong casts
as a formidable foe one commenter wrote
marcus freeze would be awesome i always
thought he suited the role elsewhere
some followers revealed how they'd like
to see mr freeze used in the sequel one
user wrote i really love how they
portrayed his character in the arkham
games and i really want to see that
version in a live action film mark
strong is no stranger to comic book
movie roles having previously starred in
matthew vaughn's kingsman the secret
service and the sequel kingsman the
golden circle as well as kickass he's
also no stranger to the dc universe
having appeared in green lantern and
shazam back when the movie was in
pre-production he was also heavily
rumored to be in the running for the
role of lex luthor in batman v superman
dawn of justice so it's understandable
why superhero fans continue to dreamcast
the englishmen as their favorite
characters but what are the
possibilities of strong gracing the
sequel to the batman there is no record
of strong stating his interest in the
role furthermore he appears to be taking
a break from dc flicks for now the actor
previously revealed that he would not be
in shazam a fury of the gods but could
he be deceiving us dr thaddeus
savannah's burgeoning alliance with mr
mind following the events of the first
film suggests that he has unfinished
business in this franchise after all
what in god's name i named the gods
doctor not the other way around
the filmmakers might opt to catch up
with strong's evil scientist and his
quest to take over the seven realms down
the line that would give him a window to
play frieze right additionally the
batman isn't part of the same cinematic
universe as shazam theoretically that
would mean that strong could play the
gotham city menace without having to
worry about crossing paths with his
shazam antagonist it's certainly an idea
worth considering the iceman cometh
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one